Hello Freak bitches. You know,
as I was thinking about, um,
what the, so with John being out and
then you got calmer, right? Like Connor,
neat things like looming in the air.
That's like what they gotta do next.
He's huge money fights. Other than
that, there's not a huge money fight.
But Connor has changed the game for
the better, especially with a fighter.
But it's like, you know with
WME he's steering the ship. Yes.
Like think, think about it. Cause he
made over, cause the numbers coming out,
their stance going to be
his paper of all time.
So he made a hundred something
million dollars, right? Yeah.
So you're telling me if you're kind and
you're part of his team, he didn't go,
hey fight Nate Diaz for
how much? Five. 10 million.
Oh and also we need your weird,
this Reebok and they're gonna pay you
$100,000 a year. Think College go.
You're fucking crazy.
Well I'm sure there's non
negotiables and one non negotiables.
The Reebok deal, like you can't get around
it, but what'd you can get disagree.
Well, it seems like you can't
get around it right now.
Everybody's wearing Reebok clothes.
Well, no, you can get this.
I'm not saying he's not
not going to wear Reebok,
but what you have to do it you're,
you're playing a different game now.
You're talking about the biggest athlete
combat sports and you're not getting
him for the 200,000 you were paying a
year. Oh yeah. That's so that he can go,
listen, I'm down to wear Reebok, but
it's a different animal now. Well,
Reebok professionally
sponsors him to site.
They do Paige vanzant just like they did
Canada different and more money, more,
but not to like think how much he
made to just wear those, you know,
whatever he had on his trunks. Right.
That's a good point. You know, that fight,
if it really did get six and
a half million paper view bys,
like they were talking about
Conor making $100 million.
If it got 5 million paper, you've eyes,
they got one and a half more than that.
It's like he's super,
that's,
that's up for debate because
you know how that came about.
So I think Dana was sitting on on
that suitcase or something and uh,
your eyes filming, right. And Dana goes,
he didn't think he was being recorded.
And Dana goes 6.5 mil and
everyone's like, damn, you know,
in the room like,
oh damn dog and Snoop's like damn dog.
And then your eye turns on the and goes
6.5 million and it shuts the camera off.
But Dana never officially said
6.5 but that's how it got started.
So Espinosa from showtimes like uh,
it's going to break the biggest
point of view numbers all the time.
But we're thinking more around four
something. Oh, like almost five.
Yeah. So who's, who knows the truth
and who doesn't? I don't know.
I liked to go with Dana on
this one. I'm sorry. Me. Yeah,
I was crunk I blasted out right now online
it says trending towards 4.6 million.
Oh cool. Domestic, domestic.
Oh well then it's 6.5.
So this is my thing with Dana.
He wouldn't just throw that up cause
he doesn't wanna look like an idiot.
Especially with he did official or not.
If he says that to you, Ryan, snoop,
he didn't think he was being recorded
but Dana wasn't just like 6.5 everybody
like she's not making that up.
If it's trending towards
4.6 nationwide and America,
that's 100% 2 million more overseas
guarantee you that our calls us says that
uh, it wasn't $100 worldwide either.
It was 25 bucks in some countries,
24 99 or in the UK and Ireland.
You know that's interesting. But still
you, you still the pay per view buys it.
It's going to be around 6.5 from while
I heard it's going to be six one five
seven does,
does the UK have like a history
of paper views like we do?
Yeah. Joshua quite the same.
That was, that was a pay per
view for them over there.
But over here was it's free.
Free. It was HBO. Right.
Cause he's not big as star that you know,
we like trade a little bit. Yeah. Yeah,
it makes sense. Yeah.
It doesn't make sense.
I just wonder how many people order
paper. I mean, you know, the whole,
the way they watch TV is different there.
And I don't think they consume as
much TV as we do with flatting.
If Connor Suetand or anything
Josh was fighting. They do. Yeah.
But I mean like overall England,
I mean, correct me if I'm wrong,
but I don't think they have
as many channels as we do.
I don't think they watch as much
TV as we did this 2017 so yeah,
by Netflix they get all that.
That's not what I'm saying.
I just don't think that it's a normal
part of their day, the way it is our day.
I don't think people in England like,
well go BBC to find,
but I don't think they watch as much.
Yeah.
I don't think they watch as
much TV on a whole as we do.
They have some great shows. No, no doubt.
But I don't think they
watch as much TV on a whole.
I think that's more of a like a,
it's probably fair to say a problem with
our lazy ass. Yeah, it's a big problem.
I watch some TV there last, I'll work out
for guts to their own president. Works,
works out at all. Zero watches,
five hours of TV a day.
He's hilarious. He doesn't believe in
bed. He thinks your body's a battery.
You think Juliet. So He's, do you
choose? You only have so many beats.
That's why he looks like he's hilarious.
He's so fat.
I was definitely an unhealthy looking.
This fight to amazing by the way,
for you paying attention
at all. Zero. Um, yeah.
But either way, I think it's going
to break the paper, your numbers. So,
but congress changes the
dynamics for everyone.
Cause now when you want
him to fight again,
you can't have them agree to
those old terms. He's a smart guy.
And if he learned anything from Floyd,
you know, when you, when you fight Floyd,
you're fighting a different animal.